forced to say goodbye holly dances to
sit by her son's hospital bed this
morning and watch his final moments
i understand why some people
get to a point i think right enough's
enough now i can't do this you know i
think we all have our limits
but i think where there's hope
there's life you know and
i do see that like with archie
i still in my heart and in my gut i
believe that art she can pull through
this i'm 100 believe that
but doctors treating him at the royal
london hospital don't agree
for months they fought with her to have
his treatment withdrawn and last night
all legal avenues ended
as a parent i want to know that i've
done everything
within my power to make sure that i
tried my hardest for my little boy
ten times it's been taken to court ten
different stages which one of those was
the hardest
um i think
the one where
my kids had to stand in court and listen
to the word that their brother's dead
twelve-year-old archie battersby has
relied on a mechanical ventilator to
breathe ever since being admitted to
hospital in april
holly had found him unconscious at home
with a ligature around his neck
she thinks he was taking part in a
dangerous online challenge
bart's health nhs trust can lawfully
withdraw his treatment after a high
court judge ruled that it would be in
arch's best interest to do so
his doctor said his prognosis is so
bleak
he will never recover
i wouldn't say
i've accepted the decision i don't think
i'll ever accept it
over a dozen court proceedings only one
of them a win
and today the greatest loss of all sadia
chaudhary sky news